[Music]
welcome everyone thank you for joining
us today but we would like to talk to
you about today is the initial steps of
our journey Nia DiMaggio to build a
collaboration ecosystem to help bring AI
to health care and right off the bat
please allow me to say this is my very
first talk in public so if I seem
nervous that is because I am thank you
may we do a quick initial survey just to
get a feeling for you in the audience
may ask those in the audience work in
health care to quickly raise their hand
yeah that's a good good number and who
of those are actually involved in
clinical research that's this right and
who is already deploying AI systems in
production smaller and last question in
that direction who is using AI in
clinical research
congratulations and if we may ask one
personal question who in the audience
knows someone who has been affected by
cancer that's a very large number so
that would further adieu my name is
Clemens or tell or for the ones who know
German pronunciation Clement I work I
have been working as a program manager
and Software Architect at Amasya helping
in its Federation and traceability
efforts thanks : hi everybody my name is
Jonathan Kaye Nevsky and I'm a
board-certified reconstructive surgeon
based here in California and I've been
leading the team at Imagi in the area of
clinical innovation so Before we jump
into our talk on data AI and healthcare
Clemens and I wanted to share with you
some words from a healthcare visionary
who really foreshadowed the explosion
big data in healthcare dr. Larry weed
you see up there he coined the term
knowledge couplers he gave a famous
ground Ran's rounds lecture in the
Massachusetts General Hospital in 1960
and he believed that there was no way
that doctors could possibly manage all
the data that was related to a patient
he's responsible for creating today's
concept of what is a medical record and
I just wanted to share with you what he
had to say over 60 years ago about big
data and healthcare what I'd like to do
is go at this problem not from the point
of view of the record I mean we really
are taking care of records we take care
of people and we're trying to get across
the idea that this record cannot be
separated from the caring of that
patient this is not something the
practice of medicine over here and and
the record over here this is the
practice of medicine it's intertwined
with it it determines what you do in the
long run you're a victim of it or you're
a triumph because of it the human mind
simply cannot carry all the information
about all the patients in the practice
without error and so the so you can see
that this idea that big data in
healthcare is is really not something
that's novel but here we are today
sitting almost 60 years later discussing
it and I think dr. Larry weed would be
completely ecstatic to know that we're
making so much effort in healthcare in
AI so I'd like to tell you a bit about
my experience and why I'm interested in
health AI and before I give you the
background of our company I made yet
my interest in AI started during
residency where as a surgical resident I
was exposed to a number of patients who
were really suffering in the medical
system in particular one patient a young
girl who died a metastatic breast cancer
who had a tumor that was completely
missed by a screening mammogram and I
remember shortly after she passed away I
spent the evening poring through her
mammograms trying to find a tumor that
just wasn't there thinking that there's
got to be some way that the human eye
just isn't capturing what's clinically
there so I was lucky enough to meet a
team of computer scientists at a media
who were working on these problems and
wanted to team up and try and find a way
to bring AI solutions that would
actually transform healthcare so a major
was founded in 2015 for a company of
more than 40 employees and we have close
ties to the montreal AI ecosystem we
have a great relationship with a
Montreal Institute for learning
algorithms one of the largest groups of
postdocs doing research in AI in Canada
and we have active collaboration with
over five hospitals in North America and
Europe
so today Clemens and I want to share
with you our big-picture mission we also
want to share with you some technical
details as to how we are building an
ecosystem that powers discovery for
clinical applications so how do we
impact the patient's journey with AI a
good example that we are focusing on is
lung cancer from screening with x-ray or
low-dose CT to later in the patient's
journey with diagnosis and biopsy then
to treatment with targeted chemotherapy
and finally with surgery and then the
long road to recovery each step of the
patients journey is important to us
creating an AI tool for each step of the
journey leads to a comprehensive care
that focuses on value-based outcomes
such as quality of life not just
mortality
the first step of a patient's journey in
the long road of what it means to be
diagnosed with lung cancer is screening
lung cancer is a leading cause of
cancer-related death despite the best
efforts made to screen the general
population mostly smokers many patients
with lung cancer
do not smoke where we want to deliver
the value of AI is detecting patients
early stage one disease where it's most
easily treated screening is usually the
beginning of a patient journey that is
filled with fear many unknowns and often
made worse by the fact that many
patients are diagnosed with advanced
stage disease being a diagnosed with
late stage disease means you have almost
a twenty times more likelihood of of
death so finding the disease at an early
stage is the best way to improve
outcomes once that lung cancer is
detected the process of establishing a
diagnosis is often a long cumbersome
process followed by choosing the right
treatment so why is this process so time
confusing a time consuming and confusing
well it's difficult to know should all
patients be given the most expensive
molecular tests right away should a
patient be started on first line therapy
if they have advanced stage disease or
should they be advanced to targeted
immunotherapy right from the from the
time of diagnosis so in today's paradigm
there's really two ways to establish the
diagnosis
it's either tissue biopsy which is the
current gold standard or a liquid biopsy
tissue biopsies are when a surgeon takes
or a colleges will take a piece of
tissue and send to the pathologist
it's often not the as good of a gold
standard as we would imagine because up
to 40% of the time a repeat biopsy is
needed or the tissue that was taken
wasn't sent for the right test to
establish the right diagnosis
up-and-coming is a technique called
liquid biopsy it's growing in popularity
and what it entails is taking in
sampling blood from a patient and
looking for bits of tumor DNA that has
shed
much like a dog sheds hair but as you
can imagine that also has its own
problems just like there's dogs that
shed a lot of hair and dogs that shed
very little hair not all tumors shed DNA
equally up to 25% of these cancers don't
shed DNA which means the liquid biopsy
would fail so what's happening is that
in many hospitals in many clinical
settings that specialists pathologists
oncologists surgeons
despite their best efforts to
communicate they're functioning in silos
they're not interacting as closely as
they should and if we want to be
successful in treating patients we need
to transcend these silos and use a ITEX
Ellery diagnosis after establishing a
diagnosis the next step in a patient's
journey is optimizing treatment
precision medicine initiated a
revolution 15 years ago
however it's yet to create the
transformational change that impacts
patients from day to day for example
there are very few drugs that target
known gene mutations for cancer and we
still don't have a good way of selecting
patients for treatment for immunotherapy
the majority of patients that are
diagnosed with cancer will not have the
option to be treated with immunotherapy
this is because patients usually need to
fail a first or a second line treatment
that is not tumor specific before their
tumor is read biopsied and to see if it
can be targeted by specific
immunotherapy even when patients are put
on the right immunotherapy as much as
90% of those patients will have tumors
that are resistant to the disease now
resistant to that to the drug and that's
because there's small cohorts of cancer
cells within that population that are
just resistant so with our platform what
we hope to do is empower physicians to
use AI to identify features invisible to
the eye that could help guide patients
to the appropriate therapy and avoid
dangerous and expensive biopsies and
molecular tests one example of where
this plays is in the area of deep radio
mix so radiomics is an evolving field
where we believe that there is
information captured an image that is
just not accessible to the human eye
patterns that relate to disease for
example is there up a specific
morphology to a tumor that could
indicate his genetic status could a lung
cancer the EGFR positive just based on
its radio make fingerprint where this
comes into play is an immunotherapy so
by show of hands who had lunch today
most people here but some people may
have skipped lunch some people may have
skipped breakfast but if I asked
everybody here to run a marathon
everybody would perform differently the
same way if I was to give an
immunotherapy to everybody who was able
to take that immunotherapy their bodies
would react differently because
everybody's immune system has a
different makeup and in immunotherapy
for cancer you need your immune system
to be primed appropriately to combine
without immunotherapy to target the
cancer so this is why many
immunotherapies fail or have such a
varied range of results because we don't
know the state of somebody's immune
system as well as we should
before that immunotherapy is given this
is where deep radio mix can can have an
effect and give insights where we didn't
have them before can we train our AI
models on CTS or MRIs combined with
pathology information from you know
histo chemistry to identify patients
immune status before we give him
immunotherapy so we know when is the
ideal time to give an immunotherapy to
achieve the best result
so finally patients have been screened
we've been diagnosed their treatment has
been delivered in the optimal fashion
but now begins a long road to recovery
chemotherapy can leave patients with
heart problems gastrointestinal issues
skin damage radiotherapy causes an
irreversible damage to the skin in the
immune system if you think about it
where we're really living in an age
where people are surviving their cancer
but now suffering more from the
treatment of the cancer than the disease
itself treating cancer is a noble and
monumental achievement but now we must
also focus on minimizing the morbidity
that comes with cancer
to transform this delivery of care we
have to treat beyond a given disease and
focus on developing treatment strategies
that can minimize harm to the patient
based on their unique biological makeup
as we build our discovery platform to
power clinical adoption it's important
to remember just how imperfect medical
training system is information is
constantly evolving in academic silos
around the world and the main medium for
sharing this information is through
publications and journals as a doctor I
can tell you it's nearly impossible for
a physician today to remain accurately
up-to-date on the latest advances in
medical science and it's even more
difficult to actually employ these
advances into medical practice so
building a platform that makes use of
federated medical data across the
network will bring us one step closer to
understanding some of the randomness we
observe so before we shift gears from
the medical to technical side of the
talk I just want to to leave you with
this point which is what we're trying to
build that a media is an ecosystem where
we empower doctors to bring their
clinical expertise to create clinical
adoption and we bring AI expertise to
bring about discovery and ultimately
together to make AI that transforms
healthcare so I'm gonna pass the mic
over to Clemons now to share with you a
bit of how this magic happens and the
technical details so based on what John
isn't just showed us we a dimaggio
belief that AI tasks related to clinical
questions are best formulated by
clinicians themselves however most
clinicians are not AI experts and that
is exactly what we're trying to enable
clinicians to do with the platform that
we're currently building a dimaggio
based on Google cloud platform mainly to
use AI in the clinicians discoveries
without having to know about the details
of AI Jonathan already mentioned a few
of the possible questions and the
clinical field where AI might come in
handy such as could we predict the
efficacy of a certain treatment for one
particular patient not for
big statistical pace but for one patient
based on information that has been
acquired early in the continuum of care
today most of the time we have standard
treatment plans we apply the most
commonly applicable treatment first and
only if that doesn't work do we go on to
the more advanced more costly treatments
and this might make sense from a cost
perspective from a public health
perspective but for an individual
patient this might not be the best
approach also could be determine the
malignancy of a tumor just based on
early imaging such as the EGFR status of
a tumor this way a clinician could
choose the right treatment early on or
to express it more generally can we
predict patient outcome based on raw
data acquired early in the continuum of
care to answer these questions one
usually conduct Salve each respective
clinical study and to give you a little
bit of a background to conduct such a
study the first step is normally to
build a patient cohort for that study
and for that outcome the patient cohort
to build a patient cohort means to find
suitable patients based on past
diagnostic or treatment results such as
a drug worked or did not work tumor was
malign malignant or benign and that
usually involves going through vast
amounts of clinical records textual
records this is actually clinician
sitting there sifting through these
records finding the right records the
right patients because these records are
not structured for that kind of
questioning and that's a tedious labor
some tasks and one of the toolkit or
tooling that we at the mahadji developed
to assist in this is based on NLP and
active learning it's a nishan can just
tag a few few reports we even can go
through all the records that they are
find the most find the best matches
based on these early selections and this
way built up a larger cohort and of
course unfortunately this has to be
happening on premise because we do need
access to the full data corpus at the
hospital the next step
just as difficult as to find the
corresponding imaging data because
remember we want to be able to based on
very early imaging that was acquired
before we even knew what's happening to
that patient to make a prediction about
a very late outcome and unfortunately as
Jonathan already pointed out this data
lives in different silos to connect that
data is not a trivial task and this is
another step where AI can help us to
find for a given set of patient the
corresponding data for an outcome in
question and what one thing we hope to
come out of this is that instead of
running on dozens or hundreds of
patients to clinical study we can
actually scale this up to thousands of
patients and beyond overall this is
going from patient structured data
really to outcome structured data which
is just the way how data is not
organized in hospice right now but now
this is where it starts getting really
interesting because once we have this
patient cohort in this overall overview
of what we're trying to do or what we're
doing is we're sending this data to the
cloud component of our platform which
we're building on Google cloud platform
and here we run an automated large-scale
biomarker discovery process to find
evidence for signals in that data that
correlates with the outcome in question
the goal at this time is not to find a
highly accurate classifier just yet but
really to provides that this statistical
validation of that evidence for such a
signal and this discovery process is
entirely driven by the clinician right
there's no AI expertise involved at that
time and this allows the clinician to to
undergo this as an iterative process for
example you might try at first to
predict an outcome based on a low dose
CT that was very early taken but it
might turn out that in a low dose CT it
just don't have this kind of information
that you're looking for and this way you
can very easily do another iteration
where you don't bring entities that were
taken later and there
of care once we have once we are
sufficiently satisfied that we have such
evidence in our data this is where the
collaborative aspect of our platform
platform can kick in namely we can
collaborate with other clinicians from
different hospitals to enlarge in the
patient base to make sure more cohorts
as I'm or subpopulations are covered
more thoroughly and we can collaborate
with aiv search as a I experts to start
looking into building highly optimized
classifier for that biomarker or a
detector for that biomarker in question
and once this has been accomplished and
this is a part that it's a little bit
beyond the scope of this talk
productization process can be undergone
going to really produce a clinical crate
biomarker in the end that can truly
affect patient care so if you allow me
to go a little bit more into detail how
this discovery process looks like
so as Jonathan already said it's based
on recent Advanta advancements in the
field code be called radiomics where the
idea is to use image features which are
hidden to the human eye to directly to
do as a patient outcome to do that we
bring the imaging data together with the
output information at the outcome
information into Google Cloud here as
example we have a image of a pre
segmented liver but this really is just
a representation of a patient patient
data is that a bigger patient data set
and afterwards we apply a suite of
pre-trained independent independent
feature extractions to that data and for
possible examples here for these feature
extractors to give you an idea is those
could be models that look for a blob
with a fuzzy context or a blob into
which a lot of lines lead into but all
of these feature extractors they are not
outcomes specific they can be used for
any kind of outcomes and there we have
we have thousands of them that we all
apply every feature extractor to every
single item and in
for data and each feature extractable
present us afterwards with an individual
result we have a colorful map here to
showcase a little bit better but in the
end those are just numeric values on a
continuous scale all of these results
are then aggregated and this allows us
to find the set of features which best
correlates with the outcome in question
and this set of features would be our
preliminary biomarker and just to
reiterate the goal is really here to
look for the evidence of such signals
corresponding to the features not
necessarily the best possible accuracy
at that time just to give it a little
bit of a technical twist how we
implement how we implemented that on
Google cloud we we upload the data into
Google Cloud storage we do run a
front-end in the front base and kiba
neediest engine which then sends all
this data into this multitude of either
sort of tensorflow models or extractors
of other kinds for which we could use
humanities engine or cloud functions the
idea here really is to make use of the
scalability that we get out of this to
have on-demand scalability to to run
this amount of computation and for the
results then be utilized bigquery to run
our analysis and present the result back
to the clinician now when we're talking
about feature extractions and models etc
in the clinical context there are a few
peculiarities about medical data that
one really needs to be aware about it is
different data first of all we have
highly imbalanced datasets that means
we'll be looking for a needle in the
haystack
Jonathan mentions the example of
screening we were looking for a few
patients who are affected by a disease
in a population of very very many and
this gets even worse for rare diseases
also what we are trying me to predict is
potential treatment efficacy for people
for whom the standard treatment would
not work so those are rather the rare
cases also we are dealing with very tiny
lesions in large data so for example
other examples of pulmonary embolisms
and one day I'm on there honestly this
is a few crepe pixels in a bunch of a
lot more great pixels that's not an easy
one to find and to make matters worse
this data tends to be not two but three
or four dimensional for longitudinal
studies so a lot of the standard machine
learning pre-processing steps such as
scaling down your data it just won't
work because you pretty much lose all
the information to make matters worse we
have a lot of variability in our data so
it features certain contexts can
manifest itself differently depending on
on age ethnicity gender genotype but
also anamnesis of a patient for example
we're talking about trying to find the
non-smokers in a screening process but
if we train our model primarily with
smokers most of them might exhibit
certain secondary symptoms such as
emphysema so we have to make sure that
our model doesn't just pick up on the
emphysema but really goes for what we're
looking for and there are a lot of
device specific artifacts and these
images so what we see here this is not
how an imaging modality really acquires
an image in the case of an MRI they're
dealing with disturbance in the
disturbances in a magnetic field this is
just a visual visual representation for
human consumption the process of going
from the real physical data to the to
the visual data
this is manufacturer specific and those
are artifacts that we need to account
for luckily we're not left with our
tools so we very often deploy a
mechanism called curriculum learning for
example to deal with tiny lesions or
imbalance data
the idea behind curriculum learning is
that you really start with a model that
trains on a very small subset on a patch
of the data and then as the model learns
this we continue
continuously increase the amount of data
the amount of context that we present to
the model it works just as well for
imbalanced datasets we can start with a
rather balanced data set and then go to
imbalanced it by bit to account for the
variability and vendor specific
artifacts we just have to have enough
data to have a sufficient representation
of all these problems in our data set
but what I'm trying to get it is that
we're dealing with a lot of data and we
are dealing with models that
deep that are complex that need a long
time to learn and this was one of the
reasons for us to go onto Google cloud
with this problem because here of course
we can make use of the near infinite
amount of resources and especially for
us tensorflow ml engine TB use this
whole stack works really well to address
the complexity of our models because we
get both the data parallelism and the
model parallelism with reasonably low
effort know when we're talking about
when I was talking about feature
extractors which are used by clinicians
for this discovery process I mentioned
that there are pre-trained models which
of course raises the question how are
these model train how are they built how
can i experts collaborate this clinician
to build such feature extractors and
this is one of the use cases for our
proprietary platform which we call
evidence a bit of additional information
when working with clinical data as I'm
sure all of you who work in healthcare
know working with clinical data is
highly regulated some of the regulatory
frameworks are HIPAA no GDP our Health
Canada has their own and I don't want to
give an exhaustive overview I cannot
give legal advice but what it boils down
to for us is this first of all we of
course have to anonymize the data HIPAA
for example provides a list of fields
that needs to be removed before data can
leave on the hospital premises and we
need to do to apply the anonymous a
anonymization the identification of the
data which means assigning random
identifiers rather than using the
original hospital generated ones but it
does it does not stop there data for
clinical research can only be used based
on patient consent and institutional
approval there are higher BER B's that
stands for institutional or ethics
review board depending on where one
lives and they grant ethics approval for
clinical studies the problem is this
consent and those approvals is that they
can be revoked
so a patient would walk into hospitals a
yeah I gave past consent for this
technical study but I changed my mind
and in the case of such a revocation we
have to be able to delete the patient's
data but also to be on the safe side any
kind of derived data this can be
something simple such as I had a CT scan
and I cropped it and saved this crop but
this could also be something more
complicated especially in the context of
machine learning where models are
represented by weights weights are
affected by the patient's data that went
into the training process now if you're
thinking about models such as auto
encoders and generative models it's hard
to guarantee that there is not some
detailed information about that patient
inside a model that would allow to
regenerate the patient's data so to be
on the safe side we said we even want to
delete those weights in the case of such
an application of course being able to
revoke means we have to actually trace
all of this in the first place we have
to make sure we know for every single
patient what happened to his or her data
in the cloud and this does not just mean
the data once it gets uploaded but also
any subsequent processing step that we
might apply to the data and to give a
fairly high-level overview of how we
achieved this in CCP is we so we upload
data from hospitals into the cloud we
run a data ingestion process which
brings the data into a data lake but
before any kind of operation is
happening on a piece of data we always
make sure we create a trace lock entry
that the courts for which patient what
data has been done what to any kind of
data processing that we run in the cloud
we first create a dedicated data set for
which is which means we create a Google
Cloud Storage bucket and to which we
copy data out of our data leak to make
sure no single process can ever access
this data this is really a highly
secured data storage that nobody has
access to for every process we created
that
okay the data set and this is something
for us very easy to trace and it's just
it's easy to show that this works
reliably because only what goes into
this data set can be accessed by the
data processing step data processing
this could be image pre-processing model
training anything like this any kind of
output produced by a data processing
step such as crop images or model
weights go in a google cloud storage
bucket which has been specifically
created for that operation which again
in itself is linked back to all of the
input data and sufficiently traced so we
have really a traceability chain from
every bit of patient data throughout our
entire system to any kind of result that
we store and to if you allow me to go a
little bit more into detail on the first
piece of this puzzle the data ingestion
the first step happens on premise where
we receive a cohort and then we uploaded
into inbox which is hospital specific we
can make use here of service accounts
which is specific to the hospital and so
only this hospital has access to this
inbox it we have an ingestion process
which then copies the data into our data
lake only after making sure that the
proper trace log entries are being
created one thing that we also did to
the inbox has recreated all the deletion
rules because when a patient of vocation
request comes in you have a certain
amount of time to comply with that
request and we really try to build in
robustness from the beginning so what if
this ingest that doesn't run and the
data just sits in this inbox bucket as
an orphan if a patient with a location
request came in this data would still
exist we would have a problem so we just
delete this data after a couple of days
automatically but not to the real meat
of the matter how can our AI researchers
use our platform for their everyday work
and our goal here was to give maximum
flexibility to AI researchers and often
that involves running not just single
trainings
but long workflows with multiple stages
and conditional steps of pre-processing
training and analysis visualization etc
so we want to enable researchers to do
this we're still maintaining full
control over the data and ensuring
traceability and the overall idea for us
was we don't have the mountain come to
the profit but the profit to the
mountain which means that we have a
secured area where all the data storage
and execution is happening and in any
kind of processing step via the training
data free processing is encapsulated as
a container or zip file containing ml
engine code and then submitted along
with a query into our system where we
running this query on the data service
and produce data bucket which I
mentioned before which is given to the
training the training runs on that data
and produces all the output in an output
bucket which can then be readjusted for
subsequent use by later stages in that
workflow and again the one of the
important things there is that each one
of these steps each one of these arrows
leads to according entries in our trace
log which means even for this derived
data that gets we ingest 'add into the
data like we always know which original
patient that came from a few other
google techniques that we use is we have
a purse per training or process service
accounts which are the only ones then
allowed to access this bucket this way
we can really make sure that every
training can only access the data it's
supposed to but at the same time that
every bit of data we have can only be
accessed by the training that's supposed
to to access this data and by linking
every data along along this way back to
the original individual patient data and
the patient they had the identified
patient identifier we can maintain that
requirement of traceability starting to
go a little bit faster because I'm
noticing you're running a little bit
short on time we then on top of this to
make it really easy to use created a lot
of CL eyes and front ends and run the
face function as a service and cloud
functions to model these workflows
in one example I wanted to give a gift
as we have running the project which
involves colonoscopy they receive
colonoscopy videos from which we have to
extract frames these frames have to be
prepared we have to identify off the
type of lighting that was used for which
we have our own models to do this then
there is some manual tagging involved by
clinicians and only after all of this
can we actually start building cohorts
because only then do we know what we're
dealing with so then we can build
cohorts and then feed this into training
and each one of these steps undergoes
this full loop so that final model that
comes out of this training we can still
trace back to every single video that
might have affected that model and of
course the reason why we going through
all this hassle is to ensure the voke
ability and as I said before a patient
might walk any day into the hospital and
say I gave you consent but I changed my
mind I want you to undo this it has to
happen on premise because we have to be
we have to look up the de-identified
identifier but the important piece is
really we sent this request into the
cloud where everyone's process that we
call no - Tommen the bokor and this
process can then use all this
information that we previously stored in
the trace lock to identify every single
location of related data to that patient
in Viet our data like Indy says any kind
of bucket running trainings metadata
anything can be deleted or will be
deleted sorry and a report will be
generated which is then sent back to the
hospital and that's just one of the
requirements that we have to have this
full loop from the on-premise through
the cloud back to the hospital
now to bridging back to the biomarker
discovery process of course all these
feature extractors that we mentioned
before are models that have been trained
through this platform those are models
that are deployed that one somewhere
that I used for the biomarker discovery
process in the case of such a vocation
what this allows us to do is to
automatically retrain the affected
models just in this case without the
data of that one patient that just
you should have a vocational request you
can retrain these models making sure all
accuracy requirements for every possible
sub population are still being met and
then automatically redeploy this model
and this way kind of ensuring a
continuous service for our biomarker
discovery platform so this is where we
are today ongoing work that we're
currently pursuing is that we really
want to improve the trust ability of our
platform you want to make it easy for
patients to trust the platform that
we're building to make people
comfortable when they contribute to
clinical studies because one obvious
thing nono talk in this time and age can
lift without mentioning blockchain is to
use blockchain and one of the areas that
we think it could really be beneficial
is to use blockchains capabilities as an
immutable ledger where we can issue
receipts to patients and hospital saying
yes we've received this data or we
received this verification request and
there would be no way to to wriggle out
of that responsibility that comes with
this data of that verification request
in the end is it the solution to all our
problems probably not and if anybody in
the audience has any ideas I would love
to talk about that after the talk I
don't know how to model deletion this
blockchain how do I guarantee that
something has been deleted and there's
no copy any the left of it so there's
always a component of trust left in such
a system you have to trust the system or
you have to trust the company or you
have to trust a regulator or you have to
trust the blockchain implementation a
fully trust list system not but we can
really try to improve trust for patients
and hospitals we're also looking into
implementing certain cryptographic Aaron
T's proxy R encryption to be able to say
we can use cryptography to guarantee
that only certain processes can access
the data that are that they are supposed
to access and one next step of that
could be this could allow us to really
further patient engagement by modeling
that
process of consent through cryptographic
Aran teeth where a patient by V
encrypting key is specific to a certain
clinical study or or training to be done
but their own key could explicitly give
their consent to that clinical study now
we've been talking out about data and in
the context of data mainly about patient
data but there's more to it
all of these consents and authorizations
they have data associated with
themselves that those are forms
processes and we would like to model
this as well to really be able to give a
holistic end-to-end view for all the
different processes that are involved on
clinical sites with respect to
traceability data in the cloud and
revoke ability and we believe that there
are certain areas where the centralized
learning in the cloud might not be as
suitable or even impossible for example
if you want to run a machine learning
operation on data that requires data
that otherwise information that
otherwise gets removed to the
anonymization processes it's almost not
possible to run this in the cloud so for
these few cases we are looking into
federated learning where data could stay
on premise and the only keeps the
control in the cloud but of course this
is less desirable approach just to to
the hardware maintenance and all of
these headaches so I'm pretty sure if
dr. Larry Reid was a time travel from
the 60s he would his head would spin
with a complexity of how important it is
to think about some of the things we're
thinking about but ultimately what we to
summarize what we've wanted to share
with you is our approach to create this
collaboration ecosystem which is powered
by the Google Cloud where we bring
together
health experts engineering experts in in
a way where they can not only use AI
without the health s first can use AI
without the knowledge
I but to do so on a large impactful
scale across a large network so thank
you very much for your time and we'd be
happy to take any questions
[Music]